各位同学，咱们上课。
呃，今天课程内容啊。
讲一个比较比较终极的问题。
最近啊。
呃，带着很多同学在搞创作，做投稿。
然后有些同学投的稿呢，被甲方打回来。
然后给的反馈呢，就说哎呀不精彩是吧？或者是这个剧情没有吸引力，然后呢，同学就就很苦恼啊，很多同学就很苦恼，觉得你看老师我的设定好像没什么问题。
我的人物好像也没什么大问题，我的剧情节奏哎，按部就班的也都写了。
为什么甲方总是说哎呀你这个剧情不够吸引人，你这个剧情是不是缺点反转，你这个剧情是不是冲突不够，或者是用我我喜欢说的话说啊，我喜欢说这个剧本吧缺戏感。
就不像戏，缺戏感。
但是这些都很模糊是吧？其实都可以总结成就不精彩嘛，对吧？就所以咱这个。
讨论一下哈，这个所谓的让剧情精彩。
应该怎么弄啊？
特别是最近很多同学啊，最近因为咱们在搞这个创投营啊，很多同学搞创作。
有一半以上的同学是在写短句，确实啊目前市场上对短剧剧本比较需求比较大。所以咱们有很多同学想用短剧这条赛道先进到圈子里面啊，拿短剧做敲门砖，做跳板啊，我非常支持啊，因为确实短剧现在市场很大啊，说到短句啊，就再说一遍这个这个老生常谈的一个问题。
很多同学到现在啊，包括很多听课的同学到现在会觉得老师。
我不做短。
短讯太low了。
丢人是吧？或者短剧这哎呀，这都什么垃圾，他会毒害这个世界，毒害这个社会啊。
呃，同学们啊，嗯关于这件事情，嗯，我不会去强迫你呃改变认知。但是我可以告诉你一个基本事实，就是短句啊。
这个市场已经跑出了赛道啊。
他现在创造的经济价值远大于。
院线电影啊，也就是说短剧创作这个呃这个收入啊是比院线电影要大的啊。
但是。
确实。
从影视传统影视的角度会觉得短剧比较low，比较不入流，或者是我们耻鱼去做短剧啊。
呃，这种事情在我这几十年的。
这个生涯当中啊，我见到过很多次，就现在大家联合起来抵制短剧。
我见到过很多次，比如说。
呃，21世纪初的时候啊，当时大家抵制互联网，因为刚刚有互联网，互联网在人群当中普及。当时大家说这个互联网啊会产生很多垃圾信息。
也会让很多垃圾人可以发声音。你就像现在任何人都可以在互联网上说话啊，在21世纪之前是不可能的。
啊，大部分人是没有渠道去发出自己的声音的。所以当时呢传统媒体曾经召开大会啊，也也曾经。
这个这个发表文章啊，或者是请专家来站台，要抵制互联网啊。
然后呢，网络小说出来的时候呢，传统文学也曾经开开大会啊，抵制。
这个这个网络小说。
然后这个网剧刚出来的时候啊，我还参加过这个会议。网络剧由于爱情公寓是算是第一批网剧啊，所以说当时电视。
电视台开大会，抵制网剧就是主流的制片人曾经开过一个大会，那个大会我也去参加过啊。
主流这愿人参加开一个大会，要抵制互联网啊，抵制网剧说这个东西会呃话都是一样啊，说这个东西呃很low。
呃，会毒害青少年，会毁了中国文化啊，毁了很多东西吧。然后同样的例子啊。
大家。
最近那个刚刚呃又翻红的那个刀拉老师啊。
大家网上也应该看到我。
以刀拉老师为代表的呃，在互联网上火起来的这一批歌手。
曾经也被主流歌手开大会抵制。
也就是说主流大会大家能看到很多人还签名呢，是吧？主流歌手签名抵制这批歌手啊，不想让他们露头。
啊，当然也有比如说主流相声圈要封杀郭德纲是吧？郭德纲老师还曾经也用这样的方式对待过直播，是吧？说直播会毁了年轻人，直播是这个文化的毒瘤。你看现在。
这个这个国家部门开新闻发布会都直播是吧？也也都大家都接受了。所以说短剧也是这样啊。
嗯，你说他有没有low的，有没有不入流的客观存在，就像互联网上有没有low的，不入流的。
直播有没有low的对吧？网络歌曲有没有low的，客观存在懂吗？但是它是趋势，它是趋势。
所以说有一部分人会抵制他，这很正常，为什么呢？因为他们是原本赛道的守卫者。
对吧就像互联网歌曲，当时为什么被抵制？当然为什么被抵制？因为他会抢了原本赛道歌手的。
演出的份额，比比如说原本的赛道的歌手。
呃，占据着主流的平台、电视呀、晚会呀这些对吧？那网络歌手起来了，如果也能。
进入这这个赛道的话，那会抢他抢夺他们的利益。由为咱们的头袭啊。
绝大部分同学，你不是原本赛道的既得利益者。
你如果说我在传统影视混的挺好。
所以他们抵制短剧的时候，我也参与一把，对吧？哪怕延缓一下短剧进攻你的脚步。
为了你的利益出发呃，这无可厚非啊。但如果你不是。
你不是那个。
固有赛道的既得利者。
那你就大可不必参与这场战斗啊，你就选择对你最好的方式。
看看能不能。
啊，认在认清趋势的情况下啊，赚到点钱，占得点先机。
因为任何一条赛道啊。
任何一种趋势在刚跑出来的时候，都有一个公平的窗口期。
什么叫公平的窗口期，你自己去品啊，就一个东西一旦发现大家发现他挣钱啊，会慢慢的利用资源和优势，把它搞得不公平是吧？把它搞得不公平。所以说。
你自己去珍惜这个窗口气，就像电商刚出来的时候也被抵制。但是现在你单身匹马想要开一个网店，很难杀出重围了。
对吧因为那些有资源，那些那些有能力的呃有有资本的那些人，他们已经基本上把电商给。
拢住了啊，所以说。
大家根据自己的情况去判断啊，我只提供一个。
因为我是编剧老师啊，我只讲创作知识，那么就进入正题讲关于故事所谓的精彩。
所谓的精彩。
那么关于这个精彩问题解决啊，有些同学还是理念问题。因为我在跟同学沟通的时候啊，我们当然啊方法我们也要讲啊，但是我们还是要先说一下理念问题。因为一个问题它一旦出现，就一定有理理念和方法两种问题。
我们先说理念。
有很多同学到现在写一个东西，仍然不以精彩为它的主要目的。
我说过，我们写一个故事，为什么？为什么要写一个故事，要让观众看呀，并且看的很过瘾。你看这是我们最重要的目的，那就是对应的要精彩。
但是始终还有些同学总是认为老师呀。
你是一个老师，对吧？特别是我也在大学里面讲课，大学里面有很多学生会觉得老师呀，我们能不能不要老讲这些很功利的方法。
我搞艺术是要自我表达呀，我管别人呢，这个想法是不对的啊。我觉得同学们有这种想法，可能是受了某些艺术的影响。
因为确实。
某些艺术它已经不是大众艺术了。比如说。
我们说。
绘画。
我们去看画展，很少说哎这幅画好看，那幅画不好看。如果这么说，人家会觉得哎呀，这个人好像啥也不懂，没什么品味。
因为绘画已经不是大众艺术了，它的好与坏。
怎么鉴定我们作为社会大众其实已经参与不了。
他很小中了。
包括画画现在能有多少人在靠画画为生，对吧？其实已经很小众了。
所以说那些不做讨论。
包括你说交响乐。
也这个这个古典的音乐也很少有人能听懂。
对不对？那些都已经成为小众艺术了。为什么说我们在影视创作当中一会受那些影响呢？是因为电影有一度啊其实有点介于小众和大众之间，大家会觉得电影是个殿堂级的东西。
比如说在八九十年代以前，如果看一个电影不好看，你其实不太敢说。
你会觉得是不是我品位不够？
是不是我欣赏不了，是不是我的错，对吧？你会检讨自己那个阶段也持续几十年嘛，对吧？因为那几十年，所以造就在后人，他有个惯性啊，造就后面很多很多创作者都认为那是正常。
其实那不是正常的那只是那个阶段。
电影啊随着这个大家的消费力的提升，随着媒体的发展，甚至随着互联网的发展，早就已经是大众艺术了。
大众觉得你好看。
就是好。
不好看就是不好。
现在已经很难说我不拍了一个电影，然后观众看不懂，然后观众检讨自己说那是我的错啊，我看不懂。
看不懂，他也不买票呀，你也赚不到钱，你也没有票房呀。
所以说。
我们一定要把影视故事当做一个大众产品来看待。
特別是短句。
你的浪漫主义，你的自我表达都要往后捎一烧。
都要排在商业性精彩性之后。
好吧，就是先说的一个理念问题啊，同学们千万不要还有那种理念了，总觉得哎我在搞艺术。
我要我要表达我的东西，或者是别人不懂我对吧？不要这么想了。
我曾经无数次的比喻。
大众艺术其实就像是。
做菜。
做菜就是个大众艺术，甚至都不太是艺术了，就是个技术。
好吃就是好吃，不好吃就是不好吃，给我做了一碗面，我一吃齁咸。
发苦。
我不会检讨我自己的，我欣赏不了这碗面条，怎么可能啊？我把碗都给你摔了。
这就是大众需要的东西啊，影视故事写剧本早就是大众的东西了，所以别扯那个虚的。
好吧，没有那些东西了，就是伤业性就是好不好看，就是精不精彩。
那我们回到。
精彩。
让一个故事精彩或者是所谓的精彩，所谓的吸引力，所谓的期待感，所谓的钩子哎，很很多人喜欢说钩子钩子不够是吧？反转不够，戏感不够，那我们要回归我们写一个故事啊。
我们。
等目标。
或者是步骤是什么，对吧？一个故事吸引。
观众吸引受众，它根本的东西是什么？这也就是我们的方法的三个步骤，分别是吸引共情期待。
也就是说，你一个故事要完成这三个作用，或者是说这三个步骤。
你先得吸引他，你让他往这看呀。
对不对？吸引完了之后呢，要与他产生共情。我们说吸引啊。
有时候不难。
我曾经举过例子，你在大马路上喊一声，马上有人看你，这就叫吸引头花这么取宠。
但是呢。
共情就开始要有点难度了。
共情做完了之后，让他感同身受以后，我们要给他一个期待。
这叫产生追索型注意力，或者是产生追索性吸引。也就是。
产生持久性的一个。
因为我们的故事毕竟有物理时长呀，光吸引他是没有用的呀。
而且光吸引他产生不了价值。
价值必须乘以时间。
所以说想要一个故事精彩，我们依然从这三个方面或者这三个步骤去找方法。在我们故事创作中啊。
我们可以理解为卖弄，然后卖弄的关键词克制。因为大部分同学。
在这三个方面，使劲儿最大的是这儿。
甚至他以为就这儿需要使劲。
把所有劲儿都使在这儿了。
其实是不对的啊，脉动这件事情是克制，为什么呢？因为这件事情不难。
我说过，你去马路上大喊一声，或者摔个狗吃屎，很多人看你。
吸引别人不难，对吧？
而且甚至。
在实操过程中，很多时候啊。
都不是我们编剧去做的。比如说一段故事。
上来有可能吸引别人的是个配乐。
或者是影像风格。
哇，拍的贼犀利。哇，这个影像。
有点意思，我要多看一会儿。
我们说你看这是包装。
或者是这个片名，我一看这个片名，我准备点进去看一会儿吸引了我吗？片名吸引我了。当然了，片名有时候包含的设定。
这是一个穿越故事啊，那我就想看穿越故事，或者这是一个复仇，今天就想看个复仇过过瘾，或者这是一个无脑战王。哎呀，郑和正义，对吧？我就要看一个南平战王。
我们说蜥蜴有时候还是个名字。
所以你看啊它包装名字是包装的一种，但有时候包含设定，对吧？我们说包装也好，风格也好，这些设定也好，它有可能就是吸引了我们。
也就是说。
吸引是什么意思呢？观众决定给这个故事一个机会。
给你个机会嘛。
所以说。
在很多时候啊。
都未必是我们编剧干的事儿。
当然了，设定是我们编剧干的事儿，但是这里要注意。
为什么我说卖弄的时候一定要克制，就是在设定上去哗众取宠。
是不合算的。
也就是说你看啊。
比如说我说的设定实际上是指赛道，你看为什么老。
甲方总是问你的短剧是哪个赛道了？
复仇的。
是吧这个萌宝的。
离婚呢。
这个这个系统啊穿越了重生的金手指啊。
我问你问你这个其实问的是设定。
问者是设备。
但是在这个设定上。
不要去搞创新。
很多同学总觉得老师他们都写穿越是吧？
最多双穿啊，我来个六传啊，左右穿。
是吧穿越加平行。
再家未来是吧？他们不是都是现在穿到古代，古代，穿到现代吗？我未来穿到古代是吧？我就要跟别人不一样。
这个你就错了。
你就错了。
在设定上不要创新。
设定上创新相当于用奇装异服去吸引别人。
后面很难持久，会给你的共情和期待。
带来非常大的阻力。
而且。
它里面还有个暗含的原因，就是这种设定一直没有人写过。
肯定是有原因的。所以说在设定上。
不要去创新啊不要去。
那么说了半天，在吸引。
这个方法上我们能做的是什么呢？其实我们主要从人物下手。
因为一个故事毕竟是人去拖动的。
主角角色去带动的对吧？
角色剧中人去带动的。所以我们一般从人物上下手。
要吸引别人，要假设我们抛开包装，抛开设定，抛开配乐，抛开那些就从我们编剧的角度。
我们如何增加一场戏或者一坨戏的精彩程度，在吸引这一个步骤。在第一个步骤，我们能做的其实是人物。也就是说我们通过人物。
让他多旅游一会。
通过人物让他多留一。
这个方法比较多，用的比较多。比如说我们这个人物非常典型。
出来一个很坏的校长，或者很凶的教导主任拿着个小棍拎着个小包。
往前走。
是吧很典型的人物，我们是不是给他个机会，给他个机会，吸引就是要个机会。所以我说卖农要克制，我只是要个机会让你看看我后面我有大招。那么我们说典型人物。
那么你就在素在人物的时候，越典型越好。
当然，典型人物能吸引，那反差人物能不能吸引？
也能的嘛。
对不对？
也能的嘛，比如说一个特别。
看起来特别和蔼。
特别老好人儿，特别装孙子的。
中学校长。
中学教导主任，你也不知道他葫芦里卖什么药，所以说要么。
特别的典型。
要么。
特别的。
反差特别的反差。
或者特别的极致这个人物。
特别武艺特别高强。
特别帅。
是吧特别漂亮。
极致能力特别强。
极致。
也可以做到。
好吧，这就说在吸引这条路上，我们下的功夫相对不要那么多。
不要去在太搞太多设力上的创新，然后包装上或者是这个场景氛围上。
能不能吸引人？有时候不是取决于你编剧，对吧？我们说有很多同学特别喜欢写老师，我就想写一个。
这个这个赛罗朋克啊这种风格的对吧？有些同学就特别钟爱这个东西。
但其实就是。
就在这个环节，对吧？
就在这个环节。如果说这三个环节占比例的话啊，我觉得是1比2比3这么一个重要性的比例。
很多同学把所有的注意力都放在了这儿，一定要有一个创新的设计，一定要有一个奇奇怪怪的包装风格。
然后呢，把所有的劲儿都使在这儿。
其实比例应该是1比2比3，因为你这儿这儿不克制的话，你后面不好搞。你有没有想你想想啊？
你如果这里设定越奇怪，你在后面做共情，做观众的代入感的时候，是不是就更困难，对吧？所以说这儿使劲要少啊，使劲儿要少，要克制。
然后我们的编剧能下手的呢往往是人物。那我们来说。
共情。
吸引往往是很短的篇幅。
很快的甚至不占篇幅。
我们快速过渡到供情。
共情是什么意思呢？
核心就是感同身受。
为什么过去反复说，哎呦，这个故事真好，身临其境。
身临其境啊。
这是一个好故事的前提啊，因为吸引啊有时候都不是一个好故事的前提。为啥？你拍了一个戏，它先天具有吸引力。
有包装，有演员，有配乐。
他难道不给你个三五秒的机会吗？而且他还推你还推流推到他面前。
对不对？他看了你的一个小预告片了，所以说。
吸引甚至都不算是一个故事精彩的一个前提。
对吧他是个基操基本操作。
共情是个前提。
别人感同身受，身临其境是个前提。那让别人。
感同身受，身临其境，通常就要从剧情出发。
我们说这个是人物这个往往就要从剧情出。
虽然啊我们更愿意我们很愿意共情人物，但是一个干巴巴的人站在那里，我那不叫共情，那叫吸引，因为他帅。
他做事儿我们才能。
共情他啊，所以一般从剧情，那么关键词其实是放低，越放低，我们愿意愿意共情。你看为什么短剧我往主张大家写小人物的故事，即便是后来他成为战王，成为龙王，成为异国之君，成为复仇的王妃。
那他也是从苦出身。
相对好好共情啊相对好共情。
放低啊放低要真诚啊要真诚，共情一定要真诚。有这么几种方法啊，大家看自己写过的啊，看看有没有这些问题，什么样的剧情更容易让人共情。第一种。
经历过大部分人经历过，或者我们见到身边的人经历过。
比如说有个同学写了一个，我就直接举同学写的例子了啊。
有个同学写了一个这个这个都市的打工人，活的很惨啊，他想形容这个都市的打工人活得很惨。
就写这个父母双亡。
然后有一个很有担当的哥哥。
把它养大了，同学们，你说有没有这种情？
对吧现实生活中肯定有。
这个首先就是个。
概率事件，他有一个哥哥。
对吧。
他们俩也没被送去孤儿院，也没让他这个哥哥小小年纪，哎，撑起了这个家。
送他供他读书，我们说很浪漫。
很浪漫主义是？但是。
就会牺牲共情。你如果你仅仅是想写这个人很惨，同学们。
父母双全。
原生家庭。
有可能更惨。
你照样可以写出很惨，照样可以劲儿很大。
在保证共情的情况下。
当样可以接。
你父母捉什么腰？
给你带来多大压力，你在城里混不下去，他们有没有支持你，有没有理解你？
当然了，也不是他们的错，因为他们从从来没有离开过小山村，没有离开过县城。
所以他们完全不理解你，对吧？甚至埋怨你。我们说这种啊有时候共情会更强烈，懂吗？所以说共情啊选经历过的事情，然后与经历过相对应的。
如何增加共还共情的第二个方法。
那至少得是想象过的事情。现在很多同学写短句，我们说里面是有强烈的YY成分的。YY啥意思啊？不就是想象吗？
也就是我想象过的事情。
很多同学在那写爽文的时候，也是因为要追求设定创新。那个东西压根没有人想象过。也就是说他获取的那个爽感都没有人想象过，这怎么能爽得起来呢？
对不对？这怎么能爽得起来呢？比如说有个同学写的，他穿越到了古代，依然啥也不会，依然被人欺负，对吧？
然后呢。
艰难生存。我说那你这个穿越的意义是什么？
我们。
所有的穿越都是去降维打击的，否则我们YY这件事情干什么呢？就。
同学说，那我要创新呀，你们都回到古代价位打击，我回到古代遭罪去。
那我写它干什么？现实生活的罪不够你遭了，对吧？就像来很多故事写一夜暴富。
有人写一夜破产吗？我为什么要歪歪自己倾家荡产，走投无路？
我即便是写自己倾家荡产，走投无路，我也是为了马上获取一个金手指。
那是做个铺垫，懂吗？
没有人专门写一个富豪破产之后会怎样？当然有这种这种电影。
我说过电影是有这种的抓娃娃，对吧？
富豪。
幻想自己当穷人会怎样？
虽然是我们公司的。
但是我客观的讲，这个选题真的很不讨喜。亿万富豪。
扮成穷人体验穷人生活。
为了让孩子更有出息，也就是说他的价值观是。
有钱人家的小孩很难混出来。
只有穷人家的小孩才能混出头。你能理解这个价值观吗？
就他认为这个故事，他认为有钱人的家的小孩二代们。
都败家，只有穷人家的小孩才能考取名校走向巅峰。
进入大公司。
这个价值观对吧？
跟现实是完全不符。
现实生活中。
二代嘛有权有势的那些孩子。
他们能上名校。
能够走向巅峰，进入管理层。
穷人家的小孩有几个。
真的。
所以说你看这个选题。
就很不好。
特别是这种带点现实魔幻现实主义的色彩的选题。
这个选题就很奇怪。
没有人天天在家想，哎呀，我如果是个亿万富翁。
该多痛苦啊。
我破产了该多好，没有这么想。
这说句题外话啊，我的意思是抓娃娃非常的不爽文。
非常的不爽。
当然了，有腾哥和玛丽。
在那撑着。
票房呢也能low，但是其实市场上反响啊并不好。
所以说。
增强共情，要么经历过，要么我们想象过是吧？
如果我们没有经历过，也没有想象过。
那第三种方法。
叫合逻辑。也就是说这件事情我确实设定的有点新了，或者是说发展呢，观众也没有经历过，也没有想象过。
但是它非常的合逻辑，也就是说主角做出的这个选择。
是一个唯一的选择，或者是个无奈的选择。这个剧情走向让我们觉得哎姨呀。
合逻体只能这样，我给大家举个例子。
比如说写一个中性事件，对吧？
比如说我们写这么一个短句，短句开场。
我小时候曾经亲眼目睹。
其他人把我家里人杀。
我由于胆小，我躲着没有。
我们说这个事情大家没有经历过，也没有想象过。
但是非常的合逻辑。
因为它有一定程度，就合逻辑的戏份，往往要结合揭露人性的短板，揭露人性的短板。所以我说为什么？
这个共情要放低。
我曾经因为胆小犯过一个错。
你看这种情况啊，在没有经历过，也没有想象过的情况下，激发观众的共情。比如说我们村子里面有几个恶霸。
我十几岁的时候，我们村子以为有几个恶霸。
强奸并杀害了一个。
流浪的。
女性，我虽然没有参与，他们让我一块儿，我没有参与，但我也没有胆量制止。我们说这场戏是具备共情力的。观众会觉得我如果在现场我也不敢啊，我们说合逻辑的戏，你可以尝试结合人性的弱点，结合人性的弱点，或者是说叫揭露本质。
揭露本质，我我放低自己了，我揭露本质了，对吧？共情是不是就强一些，对吧？虽然这件事情大家没有想象过。
因为不是所有的故事都是爽文啊，即便是短剧，也不是所有的故事，都是爽文。
我可能也没有想象过。
但是我如果结合我经历过前半段。
是吧你看啊，我就说刚才这个案件多年前的一个案件，对吧？
我们说。
这个肯定不是爽文。
那我们怎么增加他的共情呢？我们有我们说三种方法，经历过、想象过和揭露本质嘛。
混合合逻辑嘛，既然它不是爽文，我就把想象给我擦掉。
我用经历过过河这个。
接本事和逻辑来把这场戏的共情增强。这一帮小子犯罪，这帮小子是谁？这帮小子是。
学校门口霸凌我的人。
我是个中学生，这帮小子霸凌我。
我要饭给我，那当时要钱嘛，基本都对吧？你只要给他们钱，他们就嬉皮笑脸拿你当兄弟。
你不给他们钱，他们才揍你。
我选择了给钱。
然后他们跟我称兄道弟，说我是好兄弟。
但其实是被霸凌了，被霸凌或者参与霸凌或者看到霸凌。这个很多同学都经历过，或者大部分同学都经历过。
我们说你看我们是用一个经历过的事情，事件，先把共情套进来。也就是说我放学回家，对吧？
然后呢，远远看到几个小孩霸凌。
问别人要钱。
我身上也揣了5块钱呀。
走过去。
果然躲不掉，被他们看到了，我想绕路的绕不掉。
然后他们让我把钱拿出来。
我这时候。
没有敢反抗，因为前面一个小孩反抗被打了。
我选择了交钱，结果他们搂着我补说我是好兄弟。
还要带我一块去。
可游戏厅可录像厅去玩儿。
结果走到胡同。
他们发现了一个流浪的人。
可能是个女性。
这些人。
欺辱并杀死了这个人。
我拒绝参与了。
但是我没敢告发他们。
因为他们威胁我。
不准说。
这件事情在我心里埋了10年，你看这个开场就既符合经历过。
又符合。
和逻辑接人性。诶，你看共情就做的比较透彻。
就让观众瞬间理解这个人。
对吧会觉得。
他就是因为一时胆怯陷入到这个事情里面，但是他能怎么做呢？
他也害怕呀。
在一个北方的小县城，每天要上学。
社群人找得到他的，但是那个流浪汉可能也没有家人。
所以他忍气吞声了。
我们说你看这就是共情。
再总结一下啊，共情的核心是感同身受。我们在我们在下手的时候，王耀持从剧情下手。
甚至要放低一点。
要么是我们经历过的。
要么是我们想象过的，想象过当然。
爽而用的多一些是吧？
要么。
是。
合乎逻辑，并且揭露本质的，也能引发观众的共情。那么接下来我们说第三部分，期待也是最重要的部分。
因为吸引很多时候是自然而然。
共情是基本操作，是你的前提。
你这两个都做不好，那你这个故事就垮。
根本就别写了。
这两个都没弄好，那就别想了。
但是现实情况是，大部分在大部分同学在吸引上。
使的劲儿过大，也就是说老搞一些新奇特。
老想一下子把你摁死。
就是相当于我说在广场上大喊大叫。
总觉得我在广场上奇砖异服大喊大笑。
就就能完成任务，就能征服观众。其实就是在吸引上下的功夫太多。
然后在共情上。
下的功夫。
不够。
在期待上。
不下功夫，本来应该是1比2比3的力量，它变成3比2比1。
倒过来。
大部分同学在期待上啊下的劲儿不够。
下的劲儿不够，那我们就着重说一下这个期待啊这个期待。
你可以理解。
这个呢是脉络。
要克制。
是吧。
这个呢是讨好。
什么叫讨好吧？
这个叫。
放低姿态是吧？卖弄完了，我要放低姿态，让你共情我嘛。
要真诚。
卖弄的时要克制啊。
放低姿态的时候要真诚拉观众的期待是什么呢？
画饼要豪放，也就是说让观众对你剧情的期待，你一定要给我画满，一定要画满，这时候就别搂着了。很多同学在这个地方。
使使好多劲儿在这个地方贼羞涩，贼克制，实际上拉七带啊相当于画笔一定要豪放，把所有的技巧和方法拉满。
这里主要靠人物，这里主要靠剧情，这里就靠技术了。
靠技术。
那我们说。
有哪些基本操作呢？
首先。
剧情和情绪给我拉到顶，剧情和情绪给我拉到顶。为什么我说画饼要豪放，就是因为打破很多同学在设定上贼豪放。
在剧情上不愿意豪放，总觉得俗。
这其实完全搞反了。
给大家举个例子，比如说有个同学开场啊，因为很多同学开场喜欢写。
家里人被别人害死了是吧？被别人害死了，上坟下葬啊，附加千金被夺位。
捧着父亲的骨灰下葬，很多同学写这样的剧情对吧？我就看过一个同学写这样的剧情，我就跟他说，哎呀。
女孩儿。
呃，女主角在刺己父亲的坟头被人欺负是吧？全是台词。
然后呢就被人骂哎呀你这个小婊子啊，你根本不是这个。
我们家的千金，你滚出去，你休想继承遗产，全是用语言在攻击。这同学不服，说，老师，你仔细看，我还甩了他一巴掌。
我说你给我把剧情拉满。
对吧？
豪放你就能到这种程度吗？
也就是说，你觉得对一个人最大的伤害就是甩他一巴掌吗？那肯定不是。
你既然这里要做女生被欺负。
然后很可怜这么一个情绪就给我拉满，这里不怕拉满。
我说那骨灰用来干嘛的？
阳了呀，海呀。
对不对？
我说。
那墓碑用来干嘛的？
把女主角摁上去呀。
懂吗？就这时候不怕给我拉满。
这是基本操作。这就是为什么说在做这里的时候做期待的时候就要给我拉满了。因为你把剧情拉满，观众自然担心他嘛。
好好的一个女主角，怎么能被欺负成这样？
他的加产怎么办？
他后面的地位怎么办？
不拉满怎么行呢？
剧情情绪给我拉满，当然了，这是直线的，还可不可以有变化呢？我们说可以出现新元素，新元素，比如说新的人或者新的道具。
新的人或者新的道具，还说刚才这场戏。
摁在墓碑上了，骨灰也扬了对吧？各种欺辱。然后我们说哎呀，这场戏期待就拉够了吗？可以出些新元素呀。
镜头一转，有个人撑着伞在远处看着这一切，哎，新的元素就产生新的起来，怎么回事是吧？或者新的道具，新的道具对吧？
这个这个反派为什么欺负他？可能是要得到某样东西是吧？搜遍了也没找到。
但其实他藏在了哪？诶，漏出来。
那些人走了之后露出来。
或者那些人抢走一个。
咦他又拿出一个，我们说你看是不是也可以把期待拉升啊？
新元素。
永远要借助新元素。
有些同学担心老师们老搞这个新元素，那后面圆不上呀，你放心，没有圆不上。
啊，没有圆不上的，你放心，有些同学太在意自己设计了，说老师我这里就是要让别人抢走，那他怎么又拿出来一个呢？
对不对？
那你就让别人抢走一个假的，回头再真把真的抢走嘛，明白吗？可以做节奏的。所以说新的元素，新的人新的道具。
然后呢，再还有。
比如说反转。
你也可以考虑嘛，有没有新的反转，对吧？
大家都以为他爹死了，到底死没死嘛，是不是对吧？
大家都以为他好欺负。
是不是他设的局嘛，对吧？给到一个反转嘛，期待不也拉起来了嘛？然后传统呢。
我们一直讲了信息差，对吧？
我们说信息差。
是影视当中戏感的半壁江山。啥叫信息差？就是用镜头语言交代给观众一些角色不知道的信息，从而让观众把期待加强。
我们举过很多例子，对吧？我在这里讲课。
然后桌子这儿安着那个定时炸弹，你们看到了，我看不到。
这不就是信息差吗？
当然，这是炸弹原里最基本的信息差。
集合到我们剧中来。
比如说前段前。
前几天有个同学跟我讨论。
他的这个剧啊。
前面6级。
短剧前面6集。
主角都还没有开始逆袭。
一直在被欺负，对吧？
但是呢他又非常想把欺负这件事情写的很透。
问我咋解决，我说。
你的被欺负。
实际上就是。
在做共情嘛。
让观众同情他，让观众觉得哎呀，我也是被欺负，我也是苦命人，对吧？
我说你这么长的篇幅。
不给期待肯定是不行。
为啥呢？因为它是个前提，那有没有办法呢？
我说当然有。
比如说呢，他后面是不是要逆袭？
第七集是不是要开始逆袭？
我能不能在第二集就给线索？
你说哎呀，我但是我被欺负，我还没讲够，我确实有很多特别有共情的剧情，前提是你被欺负写的很好看啊，前提是你被欺负写的很好看。如果写的不好看，直接给我删。
如果你的被欺负确实写的太他妈好了，共情力太强了，太揪心了。前提是这个，那么来我就让你写6级。
那你能不能比如说它后面是怎么逆袭的？
他后面怎么逆袭的？
这个同学设计是说，哎呀古代有个神或者有个神仙下凡。
父亲神仙下凡来帮他。
我说没有问题啊，因为设定上我不需要创新，神仙下凡帮他可以呀，我们想象过这件事儿。
我想象过财神到我家。
我想象过月老到我家，我想象过没问题啊。
那么你可不可以在第二集的时候给我写一下财神或者是这个阎王爷，他在他的处境当中跟你在做镜像呀。也就是说这个神仙在他的领域当中跟你其实有点像，对吧？
他跟你经历的事儿有点像，有些片段有点像。好，这个镜头一出来，观众会不会期待，哎呀呀呀，你也别在天上混了，你快下来跟他，哎呀呀呀你俩赶紧结成。
帮扶这个吧这个这个结成那个那个那那叫什么扶贫的对子吧，是吧？
期待不就提前给了吗？然后我们说第二集就给到了神仙在天上跟他经历了某件事情是差不多的。
给了观众这个强烈的暗示。来第5集、第六第4集、第5集能不能摩擦？
他下来找他，但找错了行不行啊？
没找到擦肩而过，或者好不容易找到了帮你了，结果啪啪一巴掌骗子啊，我不用你帮，对不对？
可以把这个期待反复摩擦的呀。
你为什么要前6集一直就干巴巴的血被欺负呢？
神仙到你家门口了，第四季就来了。
对不对？结果你一次擦肩而过，一次有眼无珠，对吧？把人家轰出去了，甚至泼人家一脸。
一盆水专家偷你外卖。
是吧。
这就冤枉人家在你门口鬼鬼祟祟祟是偷你外卖。
对不对？完全可以做。
完全可以做这种信息差。你看这就是信息差。我为什么说信息差不要单纯的理解为。
就是哎桌桌下有个炸弹，我作为主角，我在经历我的6级很惨的悲惨的经历。但是有个神仙会来帮我这件事情，是不是你提前给关众了？
这就这叫不叫信息差？
当然也叫信息差。
当然也叫信息场。
所以说大家要灵活运用这个。
继续场。
我们说你看捉奸的戏，大家也很喜欢写信息差是吧？外面。
到了你们这儿还干啥，对吧？
外面马上要上来了，诶，但是这边正好要完事了，他能不能走出这扇大门，对不对？这个信息差。
不管是主角是桌的这一方还是被桌的这一方都可以拉满嘛。好吧，所以说信息差啊，大家一定不要忘了，是我们课上着重讲过的一种方法。
着重讲过的一种方法。
他其实就是制造期待最重要的方法之一，你可以理解就是从其他视角。
再打破一下目前这个僵局给观众新的期待。当然了，短剧里面大家一般说期待最喜欢或者大家一直理解的期待就是卡点。
它是一种方法啊，大家总以为刀举起来。
砍了谁或者卡没卡哎，卡点，这就叫期待啊，总理解这种卡点是期待。其实你可以理解卡点是一种剪辑手法，是不是这一刀卡没砍是一种剪辑手法这个。
我们需要一个答案，到底怎么回事，对吧？这种情况呢，在我们短句当中啊，每一步用个几次吧，别用太多。
啊，别用太多，不要总是卡在这种卡在这种需要答案啊，需要结局的。
或者是一个阶段性的一个小结果的地方，不要一直用这个方法啊，卡点的方法不要一直用要多运用，哎，产生了一个新新人物。
发现了一个新线索，一个新的道具，或者是有一个新反转。我们一直以为。
我们这个好闺蜜可以帮我们。
但是好闺蜜看了一下手机。
反派给他发了一个信息诶。
这些。
这些新的反转。
或者是用我们最常用的信叉。
我这边倒着霉呢，我这边备受凌辱，但是那边呢。
龙王老龙王正在选新徒弟。
正在训斥。
他的几个徒弟都不成戏，他要到民间去找一找。
对吧？没看，观众马上就想到，哎，可能要找你了，好吧。
这就是我给大家讲的啊。
我们要增加所谓的精彩故事的精彩。
我们要。
从根儿上知道一个故事为什么能吸引观众，或者是他为什么能称之为精彩。
三步走。
先。
吸引他的注意力。
然后让他产生共情。
第三部最重要的拉他的期待。
一部戏不管是90分钟、100分钟，还是说300分钟、500分钟电视剧长剧。
我们如果能够一直拉着他的期待不变。
因为吸引和共情啊。
相当于是加油站。
我们本质上是要期待。
但是他你如果不吸引他，或者是他没有产生共情，你拉不了他的期待。
垃圾袋可以说是我们的本质目的。
吸引和共情相当于给本质目的这辆车加油。
缺油了，我们就加点吸引力，加点共情力。
但是呢瞪著他走。
瞪的他又不愿动他了，哎，增加点吸引力，增加共情力，然后再瞪着他走。
也就是说，期待才是我们的本质目的。
所以用的劲儿是最大的。
而不是指甲油。
不开车是吧？在设定方面加油加满车一点油也不踹就搞反了。
所以说借着这节课的机会，我们回归故事的本质，回归我们讲故事的本质，我们是要吸引他。
让他产生共情力，最终是要。
牵着他的鼻子走。
让他看我们一个长长的故事，看一个长长的故事，需要是他一直保持。
高的期待。
观众一直保持高的期待，卷而未觉得悬念啊，那些谜题当然是大悬念。但是具体到每一场。
还是要有具体的方法。
希望这节课大家能够体会一下，好吧，下课。